[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it boggles the mind the
President of the United States
reportedly receiving information vital
to the security of the nation about a
provocative North Korean missile test in
a gulf club restaurant not merely in a
setting of utter insecurity but
surrounded by and photographed by people
who could be anything from gawking
tourists to Russian agents and if this
could somehow get worse
the president who cannot be bothered
even to leave the dinner to go to a
slightly more private place where random
passers-by cannot take souvenir pictures
of a national security briefing so they
can post them later to Facebook it does
the president the National Security
Advisor this ogre Bannon and others
shown using the flashlight function of
cell phones to illuminate the
hair-raising documents about North Korea
which they are trying to read an
ordinary cell phone especially the kind
of outdated insecure piece of crap
that you and I and apparently Trump use
can be hacked remotely turned into a GPS
a transmitter a thing that photographs
documents about North Korean missile
tests as the Washington Post noted quote
phones especially phones with their
flashes turned on for improved
visibility are portable television
satellite trucks and if compromise can
be used to get a great deal of
information about what's happening
nearby Trump slandered Hillary Clinton
you could argue Trump beat Hillary
Clinton on charges of insecure handling
of emails nothing she was ever accused
of nothing comes close to this debacle
near Trump's version of the bush wood
Country Club during the Korean missile
crisis last Saturday night if Clinton
had done just this the Republicans would
have been beached her before sunrise as
the Merrill ago club member who posted
the photo told The Washington Post Trump
made the decision not to find a secure
place to be briefed quote he
he chooses to be out on the terrace with
the members it just shows that he's a
man of the people you're damn right
buddy but those people could have been
North Korean spies for all you know or
for all this idiot Trump knows resist
peace